Good morning, everyone.
I want to start today with a question: how
many of you - raise your hand - would consider
software development a dangerous activity?
Okay, not that many of you.
How many would consider an activity that involves
hostile or bad relationships, mental or physical
stress, and something called a "death march",
how much of you would describe that as dangerous?
Okay.
A good number more.
Now, what if I told you that software development
had all those risks and even more?
Probably wouldn't take me that long to convince
you because many of you can probably relate
in some way or another.
In talking with developers all over the world,
I found there are a lot of small risks in
what we do, whether it's poor working conditions,
or horrendously managed projects, or even
just abusive managers and bad team-mates.
There are a lot of tiny risks in what we do
as our job.
And so, because of that, I say software engineering
is dangerous.
Just not dangerous in the way that you might
expect it to be.
Even when we have good salaries, nice offices,
comfy jobs, basically, there are still - there's
still a lot of risk in what we do.
There is in every field across the world.
But our feel is focused on creativity, right?
And problem-solving, and really approaching
unique and new challenges.
Unfortunately, it's not so focused on how
we interact with one another, how we take
care of ourselves, and how we build our teams.
So this is a combination that easily and unfortunately
leads us to a lot of stress, right?
It can lead to physical mental illness, and
burn-out.
We see people leave our industry all the time
because of issues like these.
Is to so we can't do it alone.
We need a team, right?
Not just any team, but a team that will support
us, to take that dangerous environment we
work in and turn it into a safe one.
What does that team look like?
What kind of traits should we be looking for
in a team and ourselves?
How do we build effective successful teams?
That's why I want to talk - that's what I
want to talk about this morning.
I think it is a great way to kick off this
conference as we talk about a lot of the cutting-edge
things that are happening in the CSS community.
My name is Trent Willis, currently a senior
UI engineer at Netflix.
I love my job.
I think it's wonderful.
I get a ton of freedom, work on things that
interest me, and, most importantly, they give
me free food!
So what is not to like about that, right?
What are the primary reasons that I really,
really enjoy the team that I work on it's
because what I would consider a safe team.
It's this relatively ambiguous idea of a safe
team that I want to talk about today because
I would argue that many of us don't actually
work on a teem like this.
You might say, "Trent, what are you talking
about?
It's not like I fear going to the office of
course my team is safe."
That's not the takeaway safety I'm actually
referring to.
I'm talking about safety in a more interpersonal
sense, a sense that you can fully and completely
engage with your team and with your work.
A sense that you can challenge the status
quo if you need to, you can suggest new potentially
controversial ideas.
At the very least, you should be able to let
your team know when something about your job,
or your work, sucks, and you're not having
fun and you're not enjoying it.
As I mentioned earlier, many of us don't find
ourselves in situations like that often.
Late last year, there was a well-known management
company in the United States called Gallup,
and they did some research that showed that
only three out of ten workers actually believed
or could strongly agree that their opinion
mattered at work.
Three out of ten.
That's an insanely low number, in my opinion.
At best, that means we have 70 per cent quieter
offices, but at worst, means we are missing
out of 70 per cent of ideas that could be
changing our team, and community, and potentially
the world for the better through the use of
what we develop.
You might be lucky.
Make you consider yourself one of those three
in ten workers who actually feels their opinion
really matters, and, if so, that's wonderful,
and I'm happy for you.
But it's in your best interest, actually,
to be striving to build that type of environment
for everyone else on your team as well.
Gall aluminium found that - Gallup found that
if you could increase it to six out of ten,
you saw a bunch of benefits such as fewer
team members leaving, fewer incidents occurring,
and an increase in productivity.
I don't know about you been but that sounds
like a win across the board for everyone for
me.
Sign me up for that.
But with all this in mind, the question still
remains: how do we actually do that?
How do we build a team like this?
Today, I have three short stories that I want
to share that will hopefully provide a framework
for us to start thinking about what a team
like this might look like.
So my first software development job, we practised
code reviews.
Being a super junior developer at the time,
my contributions were often heavily scrutinised.
Which was totally fair.
I was very bad at the time and I learned a
lot from this process.
But, unfortunately, each code review could
take days.
It meant that, even for tiny changes, it would
take multiple days to land it into our codebase.
After this happened for a long time, I started
to get really frustrated, right?
I didn't feel my contributions were a value
for the team so they didn't seem like a priority
for anyone else.
I started to work more slowly, slacked off
more, and the result was that no-one really
noticed.
And so the lesson I took from this was that
this team wasn't safe for me from feeling
worthless, for feeling that my work didn't
have meaning, that I was kind of there as
another body.
The result was poor productivity and lack
of engagement with the office.
And the work that I was doing.
Now, in this story, it would be really easy
to say that the root issue here, the root
cause, the thing that we should be focusing
on fixing was the code-review process, and
that it was flawed.
That may not necessarily be the wrong, but
I don't think it was the root problem.
Oftentimes, when things go wrong, we want
to point to something that's really easy to
fix.
So, what happens, is we often fix a bunch
of symptoms, and we wind up with a whole lot
of processes, rules, and guidelines, but root
frustrations for our developers and for our
team are often still there.
When it comes to building a great team, we
need to make sure we're fixing those deep
problems, those root frustrations.
We could have fixed the speed probably of
the code reviews by mandating that every code
review be done in a certain amount of time,
and we could have written code and bots to
help enforce the time limits.
What would have happened?
Myself and other junior developers on the
team probably would have felt we were being
a burden to the senior engineers on the team.
Because we're now dictating what they are
spending their time on, and that's not a healthy
environment to be in.
That root frustration of being unsure of my
contribution actually mattering was boiling
under the surface.
In this story, the real root problem here
was my team wasn't good at sharing encouragement
and positive feedback.
Now, ironically, to point that out to someone,
you have to give them some negative feedback
but no-one was willing to go that far.
So, what happened, is I had no signal that
the work I was doing was good, but I had a
pretty strong signal that my contributions
weren't that valued.
The answer here is not more process.
It rarely is ever is.
Oftentimes, we can solve technical problems
through better process, or improved work flows,
but rarely does that actually help us with
interpersonal problems.
Instead, we need to focus on fixing these
sort of issues, primarily by communicating
better, communicating carefully.
Apply some purpose, some empathy to how you
communicate with your team.
Maybe you see a junior developer, and they're
struggling with the code-review process.
So, be sure to add some positive comments.
Let them know they're doing a good job, even
if they are having lots of issues with the
code they're submitting.
Or you interact with the team lead and you
see they're really stressed out.
Maybe let them know your request wasn't that
urgent, or, if you can, offer to take some
of their workload off.
The idea is that our communication, both in
our team as well as the larger software engineering
community we're in, should always have this
constant purpose of trying to build a better
environment.
One where relationships are solid and people
actually feel meaningfully connected to the
work they're doing.
Imagine the impact these sorts of things would
have on the open-source community, right?
Maybe new contributors would feel more welcomed
and actually want to get involved more.
Maintainers might not feel so overwhelmed
and burn out as frequently.
This idea of communicating carefully is really
just a subset of a larger idea that I want
to talk about, and that is mindfulness, which
is this practice of paying attention in a
particular way.
On purpose, in the present moment, and non-judgmentally.
Purpose ful non-judgmental attention to what
is going on around you is var to what I was
talking, right?
It's a relatively broad subject.
But at its core, mindfulness is simply about
training yourself to really engage with what
is going on around you, which is why it's
often defined by practices like yoga or meditation,
structured purposeful activities, but maybe
you're like me, I don't know, yoga and meditation
seem a little new agey and unscientific.
But there's been an amount of scientific evidence
and research coming out, and tons of anecdotal
evidence that these things tremendously improve
your personal life which translates into benefits
and improvements in your professional life.
As a brief example, the health care company
Aetna started conducting mindfulness training
with its employees.
After 13,000 employees took out at least one
somethings, they found compelling results:
a 28 per cent reduction in stress levels and
a 20 per cent improvement in their quality
of sleep.
I don't know about the rest of you, but there
are definitely times when I could use better
sleep and less stress in my life.
If doing so is going to benefit the rest of
my team, then it's really a pretty compelling
reason for me at least to give this a shot.
I would recommend you start with an app called
Headspace.
It lets you try out mindfulness meditation
in your own time.
You can build it into your life on your own
time and in your own terms, and, if you don't
like it, it at least provides a really nice
way to start a nap.
Research has shown that mega mindfulness enables
us to be more mindful around other people.
When you start to be more mindful, it benefits
your team, because you engage in more meaningful
ways.
We think about what we could be doing all
the time instead of focusing on what we are
doing with our team.
We put away our phones more, to listen to
people when they're actually talking to us.
We close our laptops during meetings to give
presenters our full attention.
We show more interest.
We have likely all had interactions where
the other person was distracted.
What that conveys to you is what it being
said is not important.
If it happens repeatedly, you start to internalise
these feelings.
No longer is the thing I'm not talking about
is important, it starts to become "I'm not
important."
That's dangerous if you want to build a cohesive,
collaborative environment.
Try to be mindful, purposeful, practise empathy
when you communicate.
Applying this to all spheres of software development
will make it accessible to everyone.
Instead of the culture filled with fear and
insecurity, fear, in particular, I think is
a really compelling reason for us to strive
towards building safe teams, because fear
is a huge enemy of innovation in creativity
which brings me to my next story.
So my second job, I got to work on an important
piece of infrastructure for a very large application.
Now, still relatively junior at the time so
I solicited advice from senior engineers and
even design committees before deciding to
move forward.
When we moved forward, I was super proud of
my work.
These people I respected, these senior engineers,
had said this seems like a good idea, and
that was wonderful.
But when performance-review came around, it
was a different story.
There were problems with the project.
And they were ultimately used as justification
not to give me a promotion.
Now, obviously, that's a huge bummer, but
the real frustrating part is they had left
comments stating that I had acted too independently,
that I should have involved more senior engineers.
But that's what I felt I had done.
And this experience led me to avoid responsibility
in the future.
I didn't want to take responsibility, be the
point person if all the blame for what I felt
was a team decision was just going to come
back on me.
Eventually, due to that and other reasons,
I left the organisation entirely.
Now, as before, it would be easy to find a
solution to this problem, right?
You might say, "You should have got that promotion"
but the promotion is just a distraction.
The real problem here is that the reality
of the work that I was doing wasn't get properly
communicated to the people that could make
decisions about it.
What that told me is that this team isn't
state of safe to take risks on, I had to be
careful about the work I chose to pursue to
make sure that perceptions wouldn't be skewed,
and that I would be reflected the way that
I want people to know me.
So this problem is known as "impression management".
Which is this idea that you have to act a
certain way to ensure a favourable perception
of yourself for other people.
Basically, you need to manipulate them in
order to feel safe.
We see this all the time in small ways.
Maybe you don't ask that question in your
team meeting because you don't want to look
stupid.
Or maybe you don't challenge that idea that
you think is bad because that might hurt your
chances of getting a promotion.
Right, these sorts of behaviours are poison
to building good collaborative teams.
Because everyone's more worried about the
impression that they are leaving than they
are about the actual work that they're doing.
And that's really at the heart of what is
wrong in the story I just shared.
No longer was I willing to take risks to be
responsible because I was concerned about
the impression I was going to leave.
This sort of fear leads teams to stagnation,
and potentially to ruin.
And it does it in much the same way as technical
debt in your project does.
When you have lots of tech debt in your project,
as I'm sure many of us have experienced, especially
because we work on CSS, it becomes difficult,
or, in some cases, impossible to make any
sort of major changes, and even small ones
become risk which right?
In the very same way, when you have a culture
of impression-management and fear of openly
sharing ideas with each other, it becomes
difficult and in some cases truly impossible
to enact any sort of lasting change.
So how do we combat this?
How do we combat this type of culture?
We have to strive in the opposite direction.
To build a culture where you can show up and
fully employ yourself in your work, without
being worried of negative consequences to
your self-image, to your status, or even to
your career.
This type of environment is known as being
a psychologically safe one, and it stands
in direct contrast to that team where you
have to be scared of the impression you're
leaving.
Psychologically safe teams feel comfortable,
taking interpersonal risks, which are things
like suggesting new potentially controversial
ideas to solving problems.
Or actually acknowledging and owning up to
your failures but then actually learning from
them.
They are risks because you could find yourself
in a position where you're embarrassed or
maybe even punished for your actions by your
team.
The sort of team where you can take these
risks give everyone a chance to contribute
their voice to discussion.
Right, their cognizant of how they are interacting
with each other.
Major players have shown that these teams
learn more quickly, more innovative, and they
perform better overall.
How do we develop this?
How do we get to a place where we are comfortable
taking interpersonal risks with each other?
The short answer is you have to start by experimenting
and learning rapidly.
I like to this about interpersonal risks,
like software deployments.
If you have an effective continuous deployment
set up, then the impact of any one bad commit
that goes out is usually small, right?
If an issue occurs, you get feedback about
it real quick, you make corrections, and you
deploy again.
And, in a similar fashion, your team should
have a methodology of continuously learning.
If someone makes a mistake, give them quick
and timely feedback, you made corrections
as needed, and you move forward.
You don't dwell on issues unnecessarily, and
you don't safe feedback for a later dated.
Otherwise, that just begets a culture of score
keeping where everyone is unsure who is tracking
their every move.
As soon as I noticed there was a problem,
we could have dealt with it a lot more effectively,
right?
We could have learned from it.
Instead, I only received the feedback as I
was being denied a promotion.
That doesn't communicate there's an opportunity
learned, and it doesn't communicate that the
safety and taking risks on your projects.
All that it really communicates is there are
personalities for the actions that you have.
Critical point is you have to give feedback.
Feedback helps us build trust, and it lets
us avoid additional process, and it develops
better working relationships between the people
that are involved in it.
And we can use those pieces to help us inform
our future decisions.
To learn faster, and be better as individuals,
as a team, and as a whole community.
So, give feedback.
Give it early, give it transparently, and
give it often to each other.
Learn rapidly from your failures, don't be
afraid of.
You have to be courageous to step out and
build this culture in your workplace.
One last point to hit on in this realm of
taking risks.
How do you generate effective feedback?
As we've seen, it is easy to over simplify
solutions to problems or identify the wrong
problem.
I'm a fan of this model.
When you're repeat - presented with a problem,
you ask why did this happen until you reach
a root cause that you should fix.
Let's consider the scenario where I push some
broken CSS to production.
Maybe our site looks like this.
My product manager comes over and says, "Why
does the site look weird?"
Well, I pushed some bad CSS.
Why did you push bad CSS?
Well, we didn't test it thoroughly.
Why didn't we test it thoroughly?
Well, we needed to ship to hit the deadline.
Why didn't the deadline time to properly QA
it and test it?
We didn't include it in the estimate.
Why didn't we include it in the estimate?
Well, we didn't consider it to be part of
delivering the feature.
Maybe we should change that.
Right, if we had stopped off the first question
here, all the blame would have been placed
on my shoulders, and we would have been done
with it.
And that leaves the developers feeling unsafe
in their position, and that's often what we
do unfortunately, because we want the easy
fix, the quick fix.
So the five whys approach here has this direct
benefit of letting you identify deep issues
in your culture the way you approach working.
But it also lets you build a safe team where
people can take smart risks.
Because mistakes get treated as gaps in your
tooling, or your training, or your technology,
not necessarily as personal failures.
Which makes it safe for you to take those
smart risks.
There are two quotes that really hammer home
this point.
The first is that you must never place a worker
only one defence away from failure.
And the reason for this is because people
aren't really afraid of failure, they're afraid
of being blamed.
We're all going to fail at some point - it's
human nature.
Some of us, such as myself, might fail multiple
times.
Accidents and mistakes happen.
If you spend every moment of your life doing
that, you won't do anything super noteworthy.
That's why psychological safety is so important
for us involved in a creative, technological
industry, because it lets us take risks with
the technology, with the tools that we are
using.
Psychological safety is vital for us to avoid
stagnation to innovate.
Having a safe team makes it easier for you
to do frameworks, try out new programming
paradigms that we will hear about today.
And best practice was also
we have today.
... quickly leading to burnout which brings
me so satisfy final story here.
I had a senior title of being a developer,
and it seemed like a wonderful role.
I was really excited about it.
When work started to pile up, there was no-one
I could really talk to about it.
I am not sure a environment and I like to
complain about things!
I started to feel burned out.
I wanted to quit.
I get it's the dream of many developers to
work independently and autonomously on projects
that interest you.
But as I've experienced first hand, there's
a lot of risk in doing this.
If you don't have a good support system in
place, then it's really easy for independence
to feel like isolation.
When work begins to pile up, you're going
to feel like your shouldering this gigantic
burden all on your own.
You can't just slug that off or ignore it
- shrug that off or ignore it.
We get stressed out by work but we feel it's
the amount of work that's causing the stress.
Because we are smart and we think we're efficiently
developers, we just work harder.
We do more work, and we build more stress,
thinking that it's actually paying it down,
but it doesn't.
So this cycle will continue until eventually
you burn out and crash or someone close to
you recognises it and points it out to you.
So the issue of my story was a lack of transparency
into what was going on and not noticing the
trend that was going on in my life, and my
team was also unaware.
Before moving into talking about how we prevent
this, I want to hit on what burnout and work
fatigue mean for those of us in this industry.
We talk about those terms a lot, and I think
they've lost some meaning for some folks.
Burn-out is a serious issue, a state of chronic
stress that leads you to physical and emotional
exhaustion, and it makes you cynical and detached,
not just in your work but in everything in
your life.
It will make you feel ineffective, unaccomplished,
despite any evidence you might see to the
contrary.
You likely won't recognise it until it gets
really bad.
As software developers, as those of us in
this industry, we are susceptible to this
sort of ailment because we are hyper connected.
It's easy for us to stay connected to our
work all the time.
So as a creative pursuit, we often feel a
personal attachment, maybe even obligation
to our work.
Since many of us are passionate.
It, we write code in our spare time that contributes
even more.
As I mentioned earlier, our industry is constantly
evolving, and you have to be constantly learning
and that's a lot of pressure.
What do we do?
How do we combat this when it feels like the
deck is stacked against us?
I actually believe the answer from a team
perspective is the combination of the two
traits: psychological safety and mindfulness.
They form a virtues cycle that combats that
vicious cycle I mentioned early.
That idea might be a bit abstract, so let's
talk about some simple examples that you can
try out.
First idea: non-judgmentally track participation
from the rest of your team.
Make mental or physical notes, even, of who
is engaging in your meetings, and who isn't.
Who seems to be engaged with the team and
who is not?
Who is speaking up?
This forces you to be present, to be mindful
of what is going on in your team.
When you recognise that someone isn't engaged,
you can follow up with them which will help
them feel valued and feel like they're actually
part of a team.
Another easy idea is to simply incorporate
and acknowledge what other people are saying.
This doesn't mean repeat what they said word-for-word
but try to incorporate aspects of what they
say in your responses, maybe something like,
"Sue had a really great idea the other day,
and we should make sure we incorporate that."
This forces you to be present and mindful
of what going on.
It allows your co-workers to feel heard and
valued.
Now, these little tricks don't seem like of
but they can have a profound impact on your
team's dynamics over the long haul.
In addition to these, we need to ensure we
are focusing on taking care of ourselves as
well.
To that, I want to talk about this idea of
emotional fitness which is simply the idea
that your emotional and mental health needs
to be looked after in much the same way as
your physical health does.
You can't doing the and expect to be emotionally
strong.
This impacts your whole life, including your
team at work.
Think about the last time you got stressed
out.
Did you withdraw from your work?
Maybe the last time I threw you a curve ball.
Did you handle it in a way that you were proud
of or, like me, maybe, did you start getting
frustrated more easily and lash out at your
co-workers on occasion?
These are the sort of things that show whether
we are emotionally fit or not, and a lot of
us - myself included - need a lot of improvement.
How do we become emotionally fit?
I would recommend that you look at at all
times from Dr Emily Arnhalt.
I want to recommend one easy thing that you
can do: simply find a couple of hours a week
to play.
What I mean by play is engage in something
purely for enjoyment rather than a practical
purpose.
Maybe put together a puzzle with a loved one.
Start writing that fan fic finally.
Or pick up another hobby.
Probably step away from the computer for a
little while.
It is easy for us to think we are relaxing
when we're still working in some capacity.
Which is why I said we need to play, and not
that we need to relax.
Playing has been found to reduce stress, builds
better relationships between those involved
in it and enables you to respond better when
things go wrong.
If you're not sure if you're engaged in a
playful activity, there's a simple litmus
west that you can use.
Inspired by a member of the boy band One Direction.
He once said when someone asked him why he
wants to play the guitar more, he said, "Someone
told me the smile on my face gets bigger when
I play the guitar."
My question is: what makes you smile more?
Try to do it for a couple of hours a week.
Don't turn it into an obligation but it will
be tremendously beneficial.
Becoming emotionally fit is an ongoing process
and commitment, but it's one that's going
to help us build a safe work culture for ourselves
and those around us.
It's going to help you improve your overall
quality of life as well.
To that end, I want you to encourage the model
behaviour you want to see in your team.
One of my first days at Netflix, my officer
came to me and said you've been here for eight
hours, you should go home.
It was a small, intentional act that communicated
through his actions and words was that I wasn't
expected to work long hours, that I was expected
to take care of myself.
We need to take care of ourselves.
If you're in a position of leadership where
someone others look up to, make sure you're
intentional about setting that example.
I think doing these things will go a long
way towards combating burn-out in our industry.
We work in a very creative, a very exciting
field, right?
That offers plenty of rewarding opportunities.
But as software becomes a more and more important
part of our society, chances are working conditions
will get bores for many of us, because most
modern ideas of how to scale businesses are
geared at repeatedly solving the same problems
through process, which is against the idea
of being creative and being innovative.
So we have to respond to this by building
safe teams.
We must be intentional about the type of culture
we want our team in our environment and our
community to have, which I believe should
be one of safety.
At this point, we looked at some personal
examples from my life, some studies, and even
a few tips of how to build safe teams.
I hope that all of you walk out of here at
the end of today, and as you're hearing the
other talks, thinking about these ideas, but
under all these thoughts I've shared my strongest
motivating factor is that we should focus
on making people awesome.
People like you all, people like me, people
like everyone that we work with, all have
the ability to be awesome if they're put into
the right environment to grow and thrive.
For the vast majority of people, that's one
of the safety security, where they can take
risks confidently, where they feel their contributions
matter, and they're encouraged to focus on
both their physical and mental health.
So, if we want to make people you a Sol, then
it's only reasonable that we make safety a
requirement.
In the same way that we make tests a requirement
for our products so that we can confidently
ship them, we need to make safety a requirement
for our teams so that we can confidently grow
our peel. -- people.
If you want to build a ship, don't drum up
the people to gather wood, divide the work
and give orders, instead, teach them to yearn
for the vast and endless sea.
Similarly, if you want to build a great team,
don't drum up people to share their feels
and implement you in processes, we have to
teach ourselves, teach others, really to yearn
for the vast and untapped potential of everyone
around us.
Thank you.
[Applause]